Britany starts off this hour in Houston
Texas hi Brittany how are you hi I'm
good how are you days better than I
deserve what's up well I'm just I'm
gonna find right now I'm just I
graduated college in 2015 I took a year
off and I finally got back and to my
career and media and I'm a single mom
and I stand home with my parents there's
been a lot of arguments about a car note
that my grandmother is helping me pay
and I think can't afford it by myself
and I have students at and I just want
to move out but I'm really scared
because they always tell me I'm gonna
fail if I move out and I'm just not
gonna make it on my own so I'm I'm just
kind of lost because you know I have I
have a one-year-old son so I'm just
really scared to kind of make that move
and I don't know if I can do it and pay
off my dad and pay off this car note and
how much do you owe on the car um it's
not in my name it's in my mom's name but
it's almost $600 a month
what are they saying are they saying
it's a bad idea um well I mean she's
helping me pay the note but she wants me
to pay all of it
I'll just get a car in my name and she's
just let that card go we had a car
previously before and it was almost it
was almost paid off and I was a cosigner
on it and she got it refold and I had no
choice because I was in college oh you
have a lot of choice else you just made
a bad choice as you can well I can't
afford a $600 car payment yeah I know I
can't
that's just insanity and so yeah you
need to sell the car the car isn't her
name it's in her name right and so she
wants you to let the car go yes we had a
car previously and when I got pregnant
she felt like okay I'm gonna give her a
new car yeah
she thought she was doing a favor for me
because the old car I had wasn't any
good and now she hopes this over my head
as if it's a burden and it is a hardened
yeah she's not holding over your hand
it's a burden you guys did a stupid
thing together and it's costing both of
you so she's right about all of that
what's that tell her to get the car yeah
you did
what's the car worth um well I don't
know how much it's worth but she has
three years left she got in a 5-year
deal to pay almost $600 a month for
Nissan okay what do you make I make at
37 500 okay and how much other debt do
you have I have 60k and student loans
yeah but I think yeah that's about it
okay so what if we did this okay what if
we said you know what mom I agree with
you well I shouldn't let you do this you
shouldn't have let you do this it's a
bad deal
let's get the car sold mom so you don't
want it you don't wanna be repo'd let's
get it sold and and those $600 a month
that I was supposed to pay for a couple
months I'm gonna save that up and I'm
gonna buy me a little hoop deal a little
$1500 car okay okay so I have $1,000
saved because I was planning to move
yeah but you can't move out you're on a
car we just sold yeah so we need to get
you a $1,500 car as soon as we can and
then you need $1,000 and then you need
to move out okay car payment any more
and can you make it on 3075 in Houston
Texas yeah you can make it it's gonna be
tight but you can make it you have to
rent something cheap you know you're not
to get on a budget I'll help you I'll
get you in Financial Peace University
and we'll get you on the budget and show
you how to handle money but this car has
got to go and you got to get you a
little cash car a paid-for car and lots
of us grew up in cars that were not as
nice as we're talking about $1,500 car
okay now are you gonna drive a 1500
ollar car for the rest of your life no
you're not gonna make thirty seventy
five for the rest of your life either
are you
no so we're gonna save up and move up in
car as quick as we can get you up to
about a three or four thousand dollar
car and then we're gonna tear into those
student loans and start working our way
through those but you need to be driving
a three to a four thousand dollar car
making thirty seventy five a sixty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
and you need to be paying cash for it
and you need to be on a budget and be on
your own out from under your mother's
toxic breath yeah all right yeah yeah
okay and so but it's gonna take you a
little bit of time to get there you take
a little time to get into this mess
you're not gonna get out of it instantly
please don't repo that car it's gonna
destroy your mom she needs to doesn't
care and she's doing stupid stuff it's
killing her yeah she needs to sell that
car but I think you need to go in and
say you know I'm so thankful for you let
me live here
and I'm so sorry this car thing has
gotten between us it's a messed-up deal
I agree with you I'm gonna start saving
him buy me a little hoopty and I want
you to get this car sold they don't want
me to buy that car I don't care what
they want what they want so far has been
a long list of stupid and crazy they're
just scared it might break down with I
don't care what they want you're leaving
it might break down but what's broken
down now is your whole freaking life
kiddo it's time to make some different
changes and whether your car breaks down
or not ain't your biggest problem is it
okay your cars are gonna break down
count on it I got a brand-new and broke
down the other day they all break
they're stupid cars okay that's just
part of life but you can't go doing
stupid stuff on the fear that a car
might break down and stay in a toxic
situation on the fear the car break
might break down or do anything based on
your mother's opinion but with money
ever again your mother is a financial
doofus pianist his yeah so what she what
her opinion is about the money don't
matter time for you to move on how old
are you
I am twenty eleven to twenty five okay
perfect yeah time to do your thing kiddo
game on game on I'll help you
we're going to put you in Financial
Peace University but you need to love
your mother from a little bit more
distance okay don't you okay yeah just
drive you crazy it's driving me crazy
talking about it it's driving you crazy
you got to go home there every night
good lord what a mess so yeah we need to
in the next 60 days work our way through
this and make these changes thanks for
the call
appreciate you hang on Kelly I'll pick
up we'll get you signed up for financial
piece we'll walk through with you if you
get more questions you call me and I'll
walk with you through this now driving a
1500 our car for the rest of your life
you drive one so you don't have 600 on
the car payment anymore walk making
thirty seventy five which is the
definition of freaking insanity you
can't live like this kiddo this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]